[Music]
ah I tell you nothing like move into a
new place doing some heavy lifting
stretching the muscles in the great guys
we I don't know why I didn't think of
this before
I mean why keep filming all my stuff at
home when I have a perfectly good
location just waiting to be used where
we always filming at your house yeah to
be honest it was actually really
inconsistent where we were what's
important is that we have this fantastic
location built on top of a harmless
Indian burial ground that rests below
the hull key remains of a print down
this ain't asylum for schizophrenic
homicidal orphans in vampire puppies so
why don't you guys get busy put it
together those very heavy prattle I
figure out where to put this delightful
Halloween ornament oh and if you guys
could place them in the order of my
favorite props - my least favorite props
that'd be great
by your loss
you don't get to take notes with me as I
watched the highlight of any nostalgia
ween the Stephen King miniseries yep
nothing like celebrating the holidays by
attacking a man who's done absolutely
nothing to me and is making his living
by entertaining others ho ho we'll show
him won't we penny wise oh yeah we all
know he's had some classic stories but
he's also has some classic blunders and
nowhere are they more spotlighted than
in the overly long and overly goofy
miniseries only this time the idea is
not to get one of his ideas to the
screen its rectifying a version that
he's hated for years that of course
being The Shining
[Music]
most are aware the stanley kubrick
adaptation or as the brits like to say
Kubrick and for the most part audiences
seem to enjoy it
that is of course except for King yep
the guy who loved 2012 and death race
couldn't stand the theatrical release of
The Shining so what to do release his
own version on TV in 1997 with a
teleplay entirely written by him it sure
too has some kingly awkwardness and I'm
here to take notes on it from my next
review so what are we waiting for let's
dive into the wish you Overlook Hotel
with the shining so our story takes
place not in Maine the hell's going on
here as we open with Jack played now by
Steven Weber being instructed how to
handle the boiler room when he becomes
the caretaker of the Overlook Hotel oh
and I don't mean breathed I mean
instructed with every single detail no
safety valves he's rated for 160 every
night you know oddly enough King the
inner workings of a water boiler
described by Commissioner Gordon in the
hopes that your obvious setup for the
climax will seem less silly isn't as
riveting as you think yeah but at least
he has some history - welcome to least
scare the shit out of the new
housekeeper we had this lady here last
summer literally yeah there was this
last caretaker Grady about a shotgun
both barrel gee I hope you don't say
this on all the hotel tours and over
there is the kitchen were old Mary
McCready cooked her husband down he was
delicious Jack then talks to the owner
of the hotel played by the shaking head
of Elliott Gould the board has decided
to put an alcoholic less than a year
away from his last drink in charge of
one of the greatest resort hotels in
America may I be frank
oh why stop now it makes me sick here
are the keys
enjoy your stay I'll not only be taking
care of the Overlook but I'll be taking
care of myself and my family well Jack
Asher is our mystery theater actor that
he's no longer on the sauce we see his
boy and wife waiting eagerly at home
played by Kirtland Mead and Rebecca De
Mornay did your dad get the job uh-huh
he and the Manny
you didn't like each other but he got it
are you sure uh-huh
that's right in this version the parents
are totally aware that the kid is
psychic and the reaction is thank you
sweet down to it that is kind of legit
reaction I mean once you have to look
forward to an apartment with a neon sign
on top of the Walgreens
this makes Jack's wife Wendy think back
quite randomly the more I think about it
too that terrible night when her husband
had been drinking too much or at least
barely imitating a guy who's been
drinking too much
[Music]
slurred cliches and monotone anger the
only thing to make this more obvious is
an empty bottle of there we go I'm never
going to another emergency ward jack did
you could stop on your own I was wrong
never happens again
I am packing my bags and I'm leaving
you're right
gotta end yeah as you can see I'm really
torn up about it but his son Danny is
having his own issues outside as his
imaginary friend Tony tries to
communicate with him Danny
hi back really so Tony all his time was
an awkwardly hovering version of the
Encyclopedia Britannica kid I don't
think anyone could have predicted that
from the cupric version I was a demonic
rendition of the Frosted Flakes mascot
[Music]
but Tony shows him some scary images of
what's to come like a killer hose oh
wait what you know King you have a
talent for taking things they're very
obviously not scary and keeping them
very obviously not scary I mean what are
you gonna do try to make folk a scary -
oh for god sakes just because you put
blood or teeth on something doesn't mean
we're automatically gonna be frightened
by it I mean he's like another instance
where you just took something random you
put blood or teeth out and that
instantly worked that was different it
turns out the horror of fine croquet
mallet was just another one of Danny's
visions though jag does seem to be
struggling as he finds himself calling
his a a sponsor who loves reminding him
of stuff that he apparently already
knows well you know what they say at the
AAA meetings don't you you know what
they say in the meetings jack well if he
knows why are you telling him but it's
still tempting for him as he finds
himself drawn to local pubs like the
tavern tavern
ears to hope of randomly toasting people
outside my window doesn't lead to ironic
consequences I'm benign so they make
their way to the hotel as they play
their favorite driving game what the
hell did my son just say course it
doesn't help that his teeth look like
someone Photoshop Napoleon Dynamite's
and mouth on to it children have just as
much a right to be made fun of as any
other person hey where'd you get that
they approached the hotel and everything
for the most part seems pretty welcoming
[Music]
here they come across dick hallorann
dick please well duck you're gonna give
me a hand are you just gonna stand there
so tick of course explains that Danny
and him share the same psychic power
that he refers to as the shining and
that if he ever needs help just to use
his power to contact him and maybe a
half a dozen times I've seen things
what were they did now
I of course I'm too sophisticated to
make any jokes about a tiny little boy
talking to a big black dick but for the
record I'd like to show you how many
opportunities I had to make a joke give
me a blast you're gonna come down the
st. Pete with me nobody's gonna tell you
daddy anything just look the other way
and count to 10 I bet you just about
growing a damn dog just promise me you
won't go in this is between you and me
what do you want me to think anything as
long as it's hard I should get a medal
for how many I'm avoiding oh by the way
be scared a door closed but that's not
the important part but so real juicy
stuff is we have a hotel de tour there's
a pantry back there there's a vegetable
bin here and to almost and to the
bedroom madam and oh my god are you
gonna show us every goddamn fucking room
how about some scary stuff
I mean aside from by the way the door
closed
I mean over an hour in and the scariest
thing we've come across is a hose and
the Encyclopedia Britannica guy tell me
you're trying harder than this gotta get
moving
oh thank god so you want to see mortars
please ah Jesus Christ the boom like in
the reflection is more exciting to watch
than this I'm at least trying to make
excuses about how it's a ghost Mike or
something hey it's about as scary as a
hose or the Encyclopedia Britannica kid
can you give us something better than
that
but finally the guy gets going and they
start looking after the place and he's
already off to a bang off story as he
accidentally comes across a wasp nest
and gets done okay keep it in mind room
mom do you think that's it's fine it's
fine they're all dead guaranteed hey
come on I thought the only wasp we
needed were the three right in front of
us oh well they're looking over a big
creepy scary hotel
you know those will lead to a lot of
other scary possibilities like bringing
groceries into the hotel putting them
away reading a children's book putting
that away discussing the children's book
immediately after they read it really
you are doing so fantastic well finally
we do get some form of suspense when
Danny locks himself in the bathroom oh
no another Miracle Whip binge wake up
now there is no Tony
there's no imaginary pal who comes in
shows you the future no we
so what are they gonna do after this bit
of excitement talk about it of course I
just got scared because okay great so
they finally decide that Danny should go
to a doctor fair enough but what kind of
doctor should he go to that's what a
sidewinder that's supposed to be good
it's not a pediatrician he's a GP but oh
my god are you serious a fall tax is
more exciting than this you know excuse
me the idea that nothing scary will ever
happen your anger oh yeah
lord knows that's much more scary than
the insane ghosts downstairs constantly
messing with your hotel yeah literally
all sorts of weird stuff is going on
downstairs and where are our caretakers
finding out how many different ways they
can say sorry oh I don't know I'm sure
you'll film every one that comes to mind
though I mean seriously are the ghosts
just patiently waiting for them to
notice what they're doing I don't want
this to be an angry police joke Oh guys
you know we pee stuff down here turn the
lights on and off the jukebox will be
fans play scary okay well whatever you
guys get a minute feel free to come on
down and take a look at it and maybe be
terrified if not just have a good night
enjoy your conversation
yeah fuck them there
I didn't scary first Billy we do at last
get a little bit more action as the wasp
nests suddenly comes alive again god
it's like those replenishing bees from
the Megaman games I think just never die
bees my god but oh that was way too much
excitement for part 1
so let's level it out with the
incredibly exciting actions of going to
the kitchen getting a container trapping
them in it taking them outside going
into the living room retrieving your
camera taking pictures of the wounds and
talking about how you can use this to
possibly give some insurance money from
it
I think $5,000 of sting should do it too
scary girls and whatever the fuck that
was and aside from the ghost once again
closing the doors every once in a while
nothing creepy is happening at all
what's next I got a terrifyingly tinker
with the thermostat
so as we begin part 2 which I'm sure a
lot of people saw seeing a part 1 was so
riveting we finally see Danny goes to
the doctor
how did Danny break his arm his father
did Jack didn't mean to hurt him but it
was drunk didn't we go over this the
flashback remember drunken Christian
Bale hurting his son we saw this why
does this need to be repeated sorry
family's mending I think it is doctor
we're trying to move on this moment of
pointlessly long riding brought to you
by Stephen King helping young kids reach
the top shelf for 40 years God even when
a setup for a scary moment happens look
what they do with it hey thank God say
then this demon army can be dealt with
later yes
hey critic we felt really bad about
abandoning you while you were moving
everything yeah you did ah we're
wondering if you wanted us to come back
and help you out Rachel let me explain
something to you whenever you call and
interrupt me you're breaking my
concentration you're distracting me and
it'll take time once you understand what
got into you Aunt Flo in town we're
gonna make a new rule whenever you hear
me typing like this
how can I hear you typing if you're
miles away whether you don't hear me
typing we're gonna fuck you hear me
doing when I am in here I am working and
that means that you don't call now you
think you can handle that I'd like to
say you used to be so nice but that
wouldn't be correct
why don't you start by getting the fuck
out of here because I'm not in the same
room with you not good no moving day
let's go celebrate with some pumpkin
taco shining what the shining the movie
look Jack Nicholson goes crazy you'll
have to be a little more specific
Kubrick movie I think he's gone crazy
and it's reenacting the Kubrick movie we
have to do something before he goes too
far oh hell no I'm not doing that
why do you know what happens to the
black guy in that movie know what
happens to all black guys and scary
movies no well let's just say it doesn't
end well well let's just say if
something happens to the critic then
we're out of a job I want to try the
pumpkin burger from Macduff oh I've fine
but they were not pumpkin McNuggets I'm
blaming you
you
[Music]
- no you're blown away with that snow
scene but sad to say some actual
suspense seems to enter the picture when
Danny is tempted to go into room 2 1 7
which he has been forbidden to go in
stop what are you doing there like
picture sort of book doc if you give
them the chance to become more than that
one here for watching good to find out
how you can own the new Encyclopedia
Brittanica I was talking to the people
at home just call this number and we'll
send you this free booklet Danny what
are you doing nothing daddy nothing what
are you doing in mr. almonds office only
enough most of the transition of Jack
turning crazy is done surprisingly
pretty flowingly
that is except for this one moment where
I think up age was out of place or
something because suddenly he's in full
nut mode with no lead-in at all what
have you got behind your back nothing
daddy
not supposed to go into any of the guest
rooms what should we do about a little
boy who cannot keep to the rules daddy I
did it go on then follow the rules they
also say there s very difficult li e e
oh and just when you thought this movie
couldn't get any more drawn out of any
more boring anymore tediously
long-winded we get a 12-minute
conversation about their marriage
without any scares any action or any
suspense what so ever what has happened
to us Jack please please try to bear
with me I hate this place now just
interested in the papers I found down
the cellar
it's dress the reason you don't want to
make
to me anymore entertain entertain we
didn't have much back and bolder but
pretty happy I know how much I bitch
things up for myself I'm not talking
about the guestroom you won't be sorry I
do
the booze and my temper George Hatfield
your husband lost his last chance
because the son sees things sometimes
it's so unfair and you know it situation
do you so after that terrifying bit of
horror we finally get to where the real
scary shit lies and all this but the
real terrifying heart that it's all been
building up to the plants don't have
snow on them anymore
oh and you know what's even scarier
having them be totally still while
playing animals sound effects over them
Jesus quite I'm gonna piss myself
whoo I'm gonna write a Doctor Who
episode about this and because breaking
in the first time went so well Danny
decides maybe doing it again will turn
out even better consequences and
wouldn't you know it something actually
a touch scary does occur here Josh
Holloway so that's where you went after
lost hello Danny when the parents come
across him they notice he's not his
usual cryptic self but rather a more
unusual cryptic self Dani hey Dani way
to get the first base you so much as
they figure on him again I will wait
till you're asleep and I will kill you
of course she figures out it wasn't Jack
and asked him to go figure out who did
it after five minutes of talking about
it of course get out of here
what are you talking about place was bad
everything bad that happened here still
here stop talking about it and just show
what's what fucking scary I don't we
don't go see she might not be able to go
at all
oh look a commercial I do hope they're
still talking when they come back from
it and they are what the hell are you
fucking serious the conversation was so
long that it literally needed a
commercial break look in books
I know stories are carried through a lot
of dialogue and obviously a lot of words
that's the medium but film is a visual
medium show don't tell I mean by God
imagine if George Malays instead of
showing his voyage to the moon just
talked about it the whole time so Jack
decides to go up there and carve himself
a which say this looks like the most
intimidating weapon around here no yeah
because you've already closed the door
186 times that may be the 187th will
catch us off guard
[Music]
alright let's get some exciting scary
and all run away like a pussy
well that's enough frightening stuff for
this scene let's go back to more talking
did you break the CD it wasn't broken
when you were in there why would you hit
that the scary thing we already saw you
showed it you showed it in close-up you
showed in faraway you showed it at every
angle imaginable okay not every angle
you know have a TV but at the same time
we know what it looks like we know
what's scary about it so why would
keeping it in the shadows scare us well
we know exactly what's in there Wow I
need a drink
god I need a drink but my god damn sold
for just a shot of cupcake vodka why
hello there kind of dead tonight isn't
it yes it is mr. critic what'll it be
well I'm so glad you asked me that it
turns out I have a lot of lost time to
make up for it's all account of this
miniseries and I tell ya it keeps
getting worse don't tell mr. critic do
tell for example jack pretends he
doesn't see anything as tensions start
to rise get your son can't you see the
bruises on his neck
are you blind overactive so Jack goes
and smashes the radio as well as the
snow scooter and pretends like he
doesn't know what's going on resulting
in a six-minute conversation about how
they're stuck but could learn as we go
Jack maybe we could listen to the
weather and we could pick a time when
they call it for 3-4 days without snow
yeah and if the forecast is wrong fuck
the conversation you can say this in
four words we're stuck Oh nut bunnies
why is that so hard but things get
suspenseful I guess when the hedge
sculptures start to come to life
[Music]
Wow not since the happening have I been
so not afraid of plant life I'm so glad
the CG artists from the Langille ear
still got work things get even more
hectic when one of the rooms locks Wendy
inside why I mean what's the point we
really think about it even if they do
catch up to him what are they going to
do given poison ivy
you're just a clumsy clod and once again
what is this all building up to
absolutely nothing oh you're here you're
jumping at shadows babe you know some
people like the first film version of
The Shining some don't and I can
understand either but at the very least
you have to acknowledge it created a
surreal scary environment and as soon as
this version started it was clear it was
much more interested in talking about
that scary world than it was actually
showing it and that was three goddamn
hours of dull so boy that sounds like a
pain you know it's funny Dominic I
didn't think this location had any
alcohol let alone a bar it doesn't
you've just been hallucinating in fact
you've been drinking toilet water for
the past five minutes
critic critic do you see him anywhere
would you take that off no I'm not
getting killed by a d-list internet
celebrity
look there's a laptop maybe we can see
who's been working on
[Music]
how do you like what are you doing down
[Applause]
okay what should be done about the
chiming I don't think that's true I
think you have some very definite ideas
about what to be done about the shining
and I would like to know what they are
[Laughter]
have you ever seen a miniseries without
a single solitary moment of
entertainment in it because the new one
sucks
and there is nothing to satirize give me
the bat
Rachel door now you stay in there until
you find something positive to say
mister there is nothing positive in the
miniseries the original so much better
well find something good yeah I know
thanks to you know Mitchell hey guys I
forgot to mention hey you're not going
oh go check out the car to see what I'm
talking about
check it out
oh really yeah it looks like all empty
was a windshield wiper fluid
good luck driving without dirt debris
all over your windows you know what this
calls for
pumpkin sauerkraut hmm Oh see ya mom
here we get another scene that seems to
go nowhere
they see the elevator has been moving on
its own and Wendy climbs in and finds
party masks and confetti who is the
elevator gonna drop or start moving so
they had to pull her out in a
suspenseful scene nope it just stands
there by God a scary thing was
practically gift-wrapped for you by the
horror God and you didn't take advantage
of it that's like The Three Stooges
looking at a PI lineup and saying what
are we supposed to do with these are you
fucking master of horror and suspense
that scare me so Danny sees the ghosts
are apparently dyslexic and this finally
convinces him to contact dick oh yeah a
dead woman knowing at your neck is okay
but bad grammar on the wall now that
shit needs reinforcements and just a
pour more salt in the wound he actually
passes by an entertaining horror
director Sam Raimi in a very bizarre
cameo I love you Howie you're one
cheering MF hey buddy by the miracle no
please Oh him for applying a disembodied
hand a talking head the scares in this
movie are so fucking weak I wouldn't be
shocked if the next thing to scare us
was a guy in a bad Halloween mask
no one gets passed over three hours of
buildup guys and this is what it's been
amounting to was it worth it
but we do start getting some pay off
with the ghosts at least as they make
themselves more and more visible to jack
my god I have antlers Oh phew
no offense silly as a guy in the Wolfman
mask but more go start to become visible
including mr. Brady as they all start to
liquor object to make him more
susceptible to their suggestions family
killing suggestions to be exact but you
might want to take that up with you he's
crossed you at almost every turn
it must be corrected he and your wife we
also see the scariest part of any
Stephen King miniseries Stephen King
give him some cred though it least it
looks like he's having fun and all this
but we have no time for conducting
fearless judge ito's we got some crazy
jack drinking jack to exploit as he
tries attacking Wendy but she fights him
off by lightly tapping him with the
breakable prop
well you know what this calls for right
more goddamn talking stare at Wendy and
Danny drag him into the kitchen to lock
him up you know son we never do projects
anymore this is nice but not only do the
ghosts let him out but they also start
attacking the rest of the family with
huh well it's good to know Stephen King
has moved on from balloons to the air
flying realms of confetti hey watch out
those look like real streamers
hello turn around
Phoebe guy croquet is still not scary
what is your deal now by God you are
going to take your medicine or I'm not
king of the nine widget diamond
formation
[Music]
come on that looks silly enough carrying
this thing we don't need to make it
funnier but when he's done playing whack
at the morni as she slams it in the face
with a ball and then somehow quite
miraculously both these two seem to keep
moving don't you think they'd be down
for the count by this point mr. Dorrance
Halloran's
you'd better take care of this mr.
Torrence
stay close darling
I'll be back see accordin Arnold movie
instead of cars and to shake things up a
bit by the way congratulations dick you
see what I'm talking about it's not
exactly inflicting spine-tingling terror
when you do this with a croquet mallet
instead of an axe
I get more Jim Carrey smashing that
clock in the mass than I do something
scary just had a cartoon sound effect to
make it complete yeah things are about
laughably silly with Danny just look at
how Tony tries to show him the boiler
room is about to blow but Danny does
find out it manages to tell his father
who seems to be struggling back and
forth between loving his son and turning
into an evil ed knockoff what could a
worthless like you know my daddy hasn't
done the boiler of pressure today
[Music]
now for my positive big nerves Danny and
when they manage to wake up dick and
they make their way out resulting in Jax
sacrificing himself by blowing up the
house because yes we all know explosions
can apparently kill ghosts total
protonic reversal yeah what's the only
way we can wrap up 237 minutes of
boredom a goddamn graduation ceremony
because we weren't
[Applause]
who knew
what is this musical rooms open the doll
know until you deep crazy yourself stuff
this is something I can't get this open
well if it's scary enough for Stephen
King it's scary enough for me
little pigs little pigs let me come in
not by the hair on your chinny Chinchin
then our heart and our box and our brown
sea
why don't you just open up the door not
until you find something positive about
the miniseries it'll clear your head
there is nothing positive about it and
somebody has to pay for it if somebody
has to pay
pumpkin guacamole
hey Doc good job doc
[Music]
welcome you know you have to die it's
the law of every scary movie what about
that guy from a bit horizon he live
Jurassic Park deep blue sea gremlin the
list goes on opening from alien vs.
predator was she black I don't really
remember her pretty sure she was that
chick was awesome why do so many people
hate that movie I think it seriously
underappreciated as movie crossovers go
I mean there's no Avengers the but it
was still pretty damn designs
okay never thought I'd have to use this
come on
we
excuse me sir I was wondering black
person come through here
why no good sir I was just walking
through reading my James Patterson novel
and listening to wrecking ball guitar of
course it is hey miss Dodger critic
random white person I found out
something the miniseries did better than
the movie
what what could I possibly be Jack's
character huh for shnizzle Jack in the
first shining was just playing well Jack
it's just another Nicholson role that
could be switched out with any other but
Kings version had a very complex
interesting three-dimensional character
that shows step by step what he's going
through and why is going through it but
it's not scary just because it's not
scary doesn't mean it's not good I mean
look at Nicholson that man was born to
be scary even in the scenes where he's
trying to be normal he's still scary but
in this version you actually feel sorry
for the character and see the natural
progression of his tragic story hey
Batman played a very emotional very
complex very dramatic your ancestor
Nicholson performance so Wow King
actually did something better than
Kubrick I mean the rest of the series is
boring cliched not the least bit
frightening but at the very least he did
explain his main character much better
than the Kubrick film did as Steve
Webber did a good job bringing that
emotion of a normal guy being tormented
to the screen despite all its other
faults that part was actually pretty
well done if if it was just one element
Kingdom managed to do something better
than Kubrick one of my heroes
critic are you okay no it's cool I just
need a sit-down think things over
a little bit
[Music]
what's wrong with them I don't know I
guess the idea of Stephen King doing
something better than Stanley Kubrick
was too much for him to take huh well
it's been a long day let's see what else
we can find the heads pumpkin in it oh
well that's perfect because I found this
website called pumpkin porn calm ooh
everything pumpkin related Oh pumpkin
Hot Pocket yes pumpkin onion rings
pumpkin tortilla pumpkin meatloaf pokey
you
[Music]
would you want me to think anything as
long as it's hard